ich hole ich und andré köthe die
deutschen sterneköche gelten als
pioniere der vegetarischen küche und
tüfteln an immer neuen rezeptideen für
ihren nürnberger restaurant es sich
bradley die gemüsesorten der jahreszeit
bestimmen die speisekarte derzeit gibt
es zum beispiel gedünstete rotkohl
röschen anlauf und mit knoblauch creme
geführte erbsen schoten seit 14 jahren
hält küchenchef andré köthe zwei
michelin sterne
das reduziert und einfach dass ich quasi
vor der restaurant befindet sich das
sogenannte knobel ausland ein gemüse
anbaugebieten noch durch vom nürnberger
ihr hingeht andree köthe jeden tag um
sechs uhr in der frühe um zutaten zu
sammeln an 365 tagen im jahr
ich kann die pflanzen beobachten will
sind auch winzig klein sind aber auch
wenn sie quasi verblühen und dadurch
habe ich so alle reifen gerade die man
eigentlich geschmacklich gebrauchen kann
sozusagen und entdeckt dann auch
natürlich ganz viele sachen die man
vielleicht nicht kennt
andree köthe pflückt auf diesem feld das
was die bauern wegwerfen zum beispiel
diese rotkohl triebe für den großen
rotkohl interessierte sich nicht er
liegt es im vermeintlich gewöhnlichen
das besondere zu entdecken in wilden
pflanzen am feldrand zum beispiel
darunter traubenkraut andere wirken bis
als unkraut bezeichnen aber für den
sternekoch ist es dass die töpferin auf
dem salat
hier ist der broccoli bereits abgeerntet
danach bildet das gemüse kleine triebe
genau die interessieren andere kröte
neben natürlich am liebsten
diese spiele weil sie an diesen seidigen
ganz glatten bisher währenddessen ja die
blüten oben am brokkoli sich ihr mit
wasser versorgen und dann eigentlich
nicht so wirklich gut schmecken nach der
ernte wird alles noch am gleichen tag
den essig brett leid verarbeitet nur
frisch entfalten gemüse und kräuter ihr
volles aroma auf den teller
vor mehr als 13 jahren hat der
spitzenkoch und restaurantbesitzer seine
küche auf zutaten aus eigener ernte
umgestellt davor hatte er internationale
zulieferer aber die qualität der
produkte an nicht immer gut in der
schule auch aus frankreich
falls uns oder bringen das netz der rest
an hier mal gut nun wieder mal nicht so
gut und wir hatten einfach die nase voll
davon
wir haben gesagt okay wir brauchen eine
erzeuger jahre langsam wie eine schnecke
haben wir uns dann ganz regional gelegt
sozusagen aus den kleinen rotkohl
röschen wird ein gemüse gericht zunächst
werden die röschen einige minuten in der
pfanne getriebe wurzeln blätter und
blüten in seinem restaurant kommt auf
den tisch was sonst meist links liegen
gelassen wird
sieben sachen und wieder hat und als
pulverfass und ganz toll immer steht der
eigene geschmack der produkte im
mittelpunkt vom küchenteam im spiel mit
säure und aromen ausdrucksstark
unterstrichen
spargel wird zum beispiel mit einer
essenz aus fermentierter paprika und mit
rosenblüten angerichtet
die brokkoli stile wurden einige minuten
in der pfanne gedünstet auf dem teller
werden sie mit pistazien cremo gehackten
erbsen und kräutern kombiniert andere
kröte legt bei seinen gerichten wert auf
einer sehr feine hausarbeiten
wenn man sich diesen beruf verliebt ja
dann braucht man natürlich ist nervig
und wenn etwas neues entsteht
es ist genau diese energie steckt hier
in jedem gericht die saisonalen
kombinationen mit teils unbeachteten
gemüsepflanzen vermeintliche unkraut und
den speziellen zubereitungsmethoden
machen aus diesem speisen kulinarische
erlebnisse
[Musik]